this is a production of cornell
university
take it away donato all right good
morning everybody and uh thank you larry
for having me i appreciate you taking me
on uh two years ago kid with a crazy
idea so today what uh well first of all
my name is senator faioli and today what
we're going to talk about uh is my
patent grow dome
and before we get into it it'll be a
little easier to explain how we got here
if i first tell you what my family
business does
there we go all right so um what we do
is we build their supported structures
my grandfather founded the company 60
years ago
i have had the great opportunity to
learn under him and
work with nfl teams uh mls teams i have
done everything from a bitcoin mining
dome this winter uh to a dome going out
to new zealand so
we cover quite a bit of ground our
structures are used for many different
things
but my passion as a kid growing up was
agriculture so i tried to figure out a
way to weld that into our family's
business
being a
[Music]
kid
i had this vision of what can we do to
feed the world right and what me and my
lovely mother back there uh in the back
row came up with was what we call grow
dome
um the concept was to feed
the hungry people of the world which was
an ambitious goal
um but one i learned very quickly you
need to make money to do that
with that said i didn't learn that
lesson until we fully developed this
design which essentially is our standard
air inflated product
attached to a shipping container with an
hvac unit in it
entrance and egress doors so that this
was a modular portable system that could
be dropped down with no site
construction except earth anchorage and
inflated uh in a matter of a couple days
so that
you could have an indoor grow space
so some of the basic specs on it um and
what i worked here with larry on
actually ours is only 100 feet long but
it's basically a
100 to an expandable four or five six
hundred whatever you can imagine in
terms of length um structure it's made
out of a vinyl coated polyester um
it actually has which is really cool uh
and it's a pretty good insulation value
for uh a greenhouse which would be r4 we
achieved that by having an outer skin
and a dead air space um there's an
emergency backup system that can come
with it and our cable net system so
when you look at the position of where i
want this to be between your
conventional greenhouse like we have
here or your standard hoop houses that
kind of blow away i kind of want to live
in the middle grounds and when the last
speaker talked about scale
and making hemp work at scale or
anything work at scale the beauty of
these as you grow them the cost per
square foot shrinks
so
you know my hope one day is i fly over
the midwest and i see a bunch of these
deployed
the cool thing about dome construction
whether it's grodom or my conventional
construction is it's modular
uh in design meaning we can change
lengths we can change widths but for
grow dome itself by simply adding in
bands if we wanted to expand our project
we could actually just add in center
sections if you imagine it is a loaf of
bread
and grow the structure in length very
easily
it's transportable because as i'll show
you on the next slide a video everything
fits into that container goes on a
40-foot truck gets dumped off
and you're off to the races
it's lasted through these very exciting
winters you have up here so i proved
that to myself
we can heat and cool right now we have
just heating
we just installed and as i've learned a
lot from this experiment we've been
running
filters to filter all the air going in
the basic premise of my structures is
air holds them up so you simply inflate
the system it's a columnless system with
positive pressure meaning it's difficult
for bugs to get in uh it keeps smells in
pestici pests out
and we can control the pollen going in
with a filtering system
and at scale the construction can become
very low cost
so this was some of my earlier visions
and designs
again i was looking to feed villages not
necessarily look at hemp or cannabis in
the beginning um and while we have
studied hemping cannabis well hemp here
um you know i think this can be a great
product for a farmer to buy and have an
excessive extension to grow high value
crops locally
through our you know tough winters i
know larry really sees this as
a season extension opportunity to get
two crops uh per season
but i still do believe
one of the next things we'll do when i
do my next study i will be bringing
grodom back to our factory we will be
doing an economic study on
high value crops being grown in so i can
give a business case
all right so
the vision in the pictures turned out to
be this
i thought it would be a little
self-explanatory
hopefully this works
all right so this is grow dome showing
up on the truck i think this is at the
loomis feels what you call it yep um so
we dropped it off that day everything
was done in a little bit of stages um
but all we did is we basically used a
jackhammer in one man we installed earth
anchors we tested all the earth anchors
we then come back a couple months later
it could have been the same day
we take the structure this is the 3 600
square foot structure
um
small crew unrolls
it i think this was a two-day process
for us the goal is to get this down to a
one-day process and as you can imagine
this was a learning curve the first time
doing this
um
we spread it out over the ground
i did beat the high tunnels up next to
me so i thought that was positive you
clamp these sections together the
sections are what i'm saying it's uh
modular we can make this much longer by
simply adding in more center sections
once we had all of these sections spread
out it gets attached to the building
you can see it simply goes together with
a little heat gun and some joints
all simple stuff all pre-manufactured in
our factory in upstate new york
where we build all of our air supported
structures
that's me getting a good day of labor in
you know
i've filmed these videos myself so be
patient with them i didn't know what
type of time limit would be under
over the top of the fabric it goes the
cable the cable is what gives you all
your structural capacity so
so this is actually one of our company's
general biggest patents
when you take a lightweight fabric which
is just a 14-ounce fabric um
when you inflate that into the cable
itself the steel cable
the cable actually
takes all the fabric stress takes to the
cable and down to the earth anchors at
the bottom
and what that does it allows a very
lightweight 14-ounce fabric to withstand
a 50-pound ground snow load uh and about
a 110 mile an hour wind load i believe
just off the top of the cuff
this is the finished product it inflates
in about 45 minutes
um we were really pleased again this was
a first first shot at it uh as you can
see there's a garage door at the end the
hvac sits within for now on our first
design
we had a generator sitting outside but
that could easily be sitting on top of
the container
and
at the end of the day
we were inside with a
uh raw field
which then larry had to get to work
planting so let me
shift this off if i could
so okay i can click it now too it's
working okay
so those are the different views i took
some shots
um as you can see at the bottom is where
all the earth anchors go in
that's the cabling system on top i was
just talking about um transferring the
load
and what was this field
just a couple months later
um larry had a ton of hemp in there we
have learned a lot and we know what we
need to do if you can see on the back
end
we added in some fabric vents to
increase airflow
to the outside to keep the space a
little cooler
this is a working living breathing
project you can see the inner skin
hanging away from the outer skin which
actually gives you your r value
um
close up of the plant
so
we have a little work to do here no
doubt uh larry but we're trying to get
to a point where we can have a very
finished end product
i just wanted to run through quickly i
know it's kind of not your guys forte
potentially but really where i see this
going is in the first few steps of the
food cycle i would i would love to see
my product minimizing pesticides
because you're growing indoors
minimizing cross-pollination
ideally because we're indoors we can get
a more
uniform crop minimize the labor
associated by using some machinery get
obviously consistent production as we
know environmental conditions kill you
one of my thoughts was to have a second
container on the opposite side so while
you have food production occurring in
the space
food processing can be done outside of
the space right in the adjacent
container so it could be a system where
the equipment's brought in the planting
is done and then the food is processed
and packaged and ready for distribution
um
i would like to obviously bring this
more localized i myself deal with a lot
of shipping in our main business i can
tell you there's a lot of
cost
uh associated with that and headache
nowadays so
i really think we can do a good job of
getting these in localized areas whether
it's hemp or just food itself
um
and then from the sales end of it uh you
know you'll get a longer shelf life
because you're not having a long
transport we can grow during the growing
season fresh produce and i usually find
customers are really willing to pay when
they can see what they're eating
basically
as i said i'm going to do a little study
for myself i would actually like to
connect with
the last speaker a little bit on the
hemp end of things so we can look at
some of the numbers but just like when
we built the first tennis structure we
owned and operated them ourselves
because once you have a business model
then you can easily go to obviously the
farmers and companies and say hey spendx
you'll get this type of return so i want
to have that all proven out as well
so in short thank you and if you have
any questions i'm around
if there's one question we'll take one
question for donato
uh i i should but
let me uh
i don't have a contact slot i should
have done that give me my card though go
ahead
so
the question was about the light
transmission
through the dome yeah so i think each
layer has 67
um and there's two layers
you have the
uh
calcs on what came exactly through which
we can i
yeah so we had a weather station inside
the grow dome and in the adjacent high
tunnel
and i believe the
i don't have the exact numbers on my
head but generally i think
the par within the grow dome was about
half of what we were getting in the
adjacent high tunnel and just to add to
that i'm working with a company who came
up here and visited the site for a fully
recyclable envelope with about twice the
translucency so we're hoping to improve
on that as well
so
at scale
you know i think i'm gonna bring those
costs into the 300 000 range for a model
that's 400 feet long um
so but right now if i'm gonna sell it
again it's it's very difficult because i
have to cover my factories overhead
so right now if you were to buy this
today i could easily sell this at 400
000
um but my goal is at scale you know the
shipping container costs are expensive
it's customized the units are expensive
i think i can take about 25 of that out
once we get to scale
uh as as long as you can put in earth
anchors which we did by hand but if you
had a machine to do
so actually to be honest with you i
normally don't key weld them on most of
our structures in our conventional
business come up and down yearly um we
just did that to prevent any you know
rain from coming through and really seal
it up tight those clamps so that flap
usually just sits over naturally those
clamps just drill on and drill off
okay
uh last question
absolutely so i want to get it to a
point where i feel very comfortable in
selling something right because
everything we do our company or my
family's names on the line so
if we have a product which i feel we're
getting pretty close to where we can
sell it and you can comfortably grow in
it the skin itself can change um the
mechanical equipment itself now i'll put
filters in um so yeah any improvements
on the skin are very low cost because
it's the smallest part of the structure
so we can definitely pass all that stuff
on
okay thanks again donato
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu